منذ انطلاق الاعمال العسكريه والمواطنون
في مقاطعه دانيت يسعون لتقنين استخدام
المياه التي يصعب الحصول عليها وان كانت
غير صالحه للشرب
وهكذا نحصل على المياه مره كل ثلاثه ايام
والمقاطعه باكملها بعد ان اصبحت المياه
تضخوا ساعتين كل ثلاثه ايام
للمنطقه وليس للمنازل والبيوت هو مع دخول
فصل الشتاء اصبحت المياه واكثر شحا وباتت
الحاجه لحل ازمه المياه
لاصالها عبر انابيب من نهر الدون في مدينه
رستوف الروسيه الاقرب
المياه لساعات المحدوده من شهر يوليو
والان يعملون على ايصال المياه لنا
عندما يحرر تلك المناطق فقط
يصل الينه ويصعد جيش الروسي للسيطره على
المدن الشماليه من مقاطعه دانيت من اجل
الوصول الى مصادر المياه العذبه في حوض
دمباس خلف مدن باخ موت وكره موتورز
والتي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني ما
زالت المياه شحيحه في مقاطعه ذلك بعد منع
امداداتها من قبل القوات الروسيه التي
تسيطر على مدينه سلابيانس في المنطقه
الشماليه من المقاطعه بينما تحوي هذه
المدينه ابار تحليه المياه القائمه على
نهر
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر